[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's bill
byrne it's time for a special edition
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast we have
uh two of my favorite stand-up comics to
my favorite people
up and coming how dare i say youngsters
to show my age
um to the uh you know funniest [ __ ]
guys and i really got to know them
last summer when i was out uh doing that
movie with pete davidson and them these
guys were just killing it every night
and they have an absolutely amazing
podcast that is now on the all things
comedy network
history hyenas please welcome giannis
papas
and christy stefano what's going on guys
what's going on what's going on bill
billy i just want to say start this
pocket saying [ __ ] mayor de blasio
you're ruining new york city yeah you
know what [ __ ] de blasio [ __ ] covert
it's not real let's get back out there
why is it not real because listen i'm no
scientist but here's the deal
we've come to the conclusion through our
research that it was created by nancy
pelosi
and that's just what it was she made it
and she's been throwing it out there and
it's time to vote to the right
you guys are hilarious i just like how
that whole point started with because
listen
yeah why is it you know what it is
listen she created it that's what it is
i feel like the only positive thing for
me
is that when it hit in march i was in
the absolute throes of a [ __ ] sex
addiction
and i think that coveted showed up to my
body was like there's no room here
i think it's just saw too many it was
like now this guy's got things he's
fired up with chlamydia and god knows
what else
so let's just move on and i beat it you
did you have it
no i never had it but i never had the
antibodies and i never had
corona you know i don't know and we none
of us none of us ever had it here it's
like everybody just knows and we're in
new york city
yeah so we don't i don't know i think
you know what it is when you live in new
york city
the immune system gets so strong if you
if you're from here like me and chris
that we've eaten so many foods that have
rat piss in them and rash [ __ ] in them
yeah
that like covet can't stand a chance
next to
the types of diseases that rats have
thrown in our body
all right that's the first time you've
blown new york we're only two minutes in
two minutes then i was about to say
oh i saw this that there was enough
ticket cases in boston
i'm just saying you [ __ ] fairy
the [ __ ] socks yeah also the love of
the yankees
so funny right we got to go back here
what's so funny about that is i have no
idea what's going on in boston
and if i i don't want to quote somebody
stand up special
but i believe giannis you did you took
time out of your stand-up special
to do a whole bit about how much you and
new yorkers
don't care about boston or pay attention
and i got i don't know
be it sports or a pandemic you seem to
be
i i think these last 20 years really
hurt you
well you know when ever since we moved
the capital
we are the history hyenas from new york
to washington
we've always been a little jealous of
boston because you know you guys really
started the country
so that's what it is but you can't watch
my special it's called blowing the light
it's on youtube
and bill burke gives it the thumbs up
even though he hasn't watched it
what did i just watch the clips now wait
a minute i don't i thought it was
i thought the country started in
virginia i don't
you know we just we we for us history's
secondary
what's first is that just we
we we we speak to the woke people in the
world
that's our top priority is that what we
say is right
and it doesn't have to be factually
right in history but it has to be
morally right well the only reason i
even brought up new york versus boston
is because i'm just trying to get things
flowing on the algorithm i was just
thinking that maybe it'll be some type
of new york boston clip
that we post i just want to get the
[ __ ] on the algorithm's good side
on this [ __ ] goddamn the gatekeeper
used to be whomever from montreal comedy
festival
now with some nerd in india on who's
gonna [ __ ] say which clips are gonna
put to the algorithm try to get some
waves
from you or joe rogan that's just the
way it works now you blew up
what is the algorithm i mean the
algorithm on youtube what
the algorithm is going to decide what
clips and
shows to to show to viewers that aren't
your fans
if it looks like you know something
that's interesting or gets a lot of
views or
similar to your audience or joe rogan's
audience or
tim dillon's audience don't talk about
the algorithm
that's probably the number one rule
you're not supposed to curse in the
first five minutes and i
opened up by saying [ __ ] the red sox so
i'm an idiot and i apologize to the
algorithm
well you must be happy about the red sox
i i don't think we have enough roided up
free agents this year we're going to
have to rebuild
get rid of i haven't i haven't watched
baseball i can't get i haven't gotten
into this i couldn't
even the islanders i'm a big islanders
fan they're going to probably go to the
stadium
nhl's been great i just can't for me man
i don't know why
it's just not having the fans there
everything seems like preseason
everything seems like exhibition and i
realized that i played sports my whole
life
and i it's one of those things i'm like
do i not love sports because if i can't
watch it without the fans what
why was i even watching it to begin with
i think i used to just do it
because it's what my dad would make me
do and now he moved to florida and has
he's on [ __ ] dialysis so who knows
he's unconscious half the time yeah but
he's got a little watch it he's got a
little bit of your money so he's got
some money to play around with my dad's
got some juice on the games yeah it's
what it is
did that guy uh did he force you to play
sports
you think he did that that's the that
was the thing like my mother would
always say when i was a kid she was like
you know tony he doesn't want to play
and then he'd be like you know my dad
would she's like no he does want to play
that back i really don't want to play
he's like you're going to [ __ ] play
and then i would just play you know
basketball and baseball and i remember
one i mean like there was no i remember
one time i got hit by a pitch
we were playing baseball i got hit by a
pitch i was like 11 years old i was
crying at home plate i just wanted
someone to comfort me
and my dad just [ __ ] you know
coaching the game walks out
and he's like rubbing my back you know
he's like you got to stop crying you're
[ __ ] embarrassing me i'm like my back
hurts
i don't want to play the game he's like
are you really going to be this the name
on the back new jersey you're
embarrassing me
he was like i cannot wait i cannot
[ __ ] wait to get home
because i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you and then i was just you know it
never happened but i was just
yeah i think for so much of my life i
just played sports
because my dad you know would just make
me do it
like division two scoring record
career the all-time leading scorer in my
college and i never wanted to play the
game but i would just still shoot a
thousand jump shots every day
just play you know baseball basketball
it was just because i wanted my dad to
be proud of me
and uh you know and i guess at the end
he kind of was
did you look back after your playing
career be like what the hell was that or
was
while you were doing it um like the last
six months did you realize like i got to
stop doing this because this wasn't my
dream
i think that it's just we were talking
about before
about like addictions and stuff like
that i think that it's just
all i've done my whole life is just
change addictions that i've had like
first it was basketball and sports
because my dad was like this is what you
want to do and i was like i want my dad
to love me i wanted my dad to be proud
of me i'm addicted to that because he
left
and my family was divorced and i'm like
dad this will make dad proud a thousand
jump shots and then boom
basketball accolades accolades accolades
and then it stops and i'm like oh i
don't want to play anymore so then
it turned to uh getting my mother's love
because my mother would say
i remember my mother said to me once
when i was 21 she was like you know i
feel like you do everything for your
father and you won't do anything for me
she's like i feel like you're such a
smart
kid and you've never applied yourself
academically and that's all i ever
wanted and all you ever did was prove
stuff to your dad
so then i [ __ ] got into graduate
school and got a doctorate degree and
got a doctorate in physical therapy
because i swear to god i did it from my
mother
i just was like putting my head down and
doing it doing it do it and then i'm
doing physical therapy for a year and i
said [ __ ] this
i don't want to do this i want to do
something for me and then i went to the
gotham comedy club open mic
and then i've just been doing this ever
since so i think i'm just changing
addictions and then eventually this will
probably peter out
and i don't know what i'll get to see
what goddess needs to do
is now put pressure on you to become the
greatest co-host
in the short time of podcasting history
and then you'll you'll
you'll achieve that too you know what
this is oh trust me the andre agassi
book did you ever read that
open i no i never read the andre agassi
book no
i've never read it but but andrew looks
like a greek tennis player from
australia
what augustine saying he he wrote he
wrote this book where
he talked about he never wanted to play
tennis his dad this is so [ __ ] crazy
his dad
decided he was going to play tennis
and he just made him go out and practice
he was crying didn't want to do it
and it's just amazing the will of that
guy and him keeping him on playing
he he's one of the few guys he want to
grand slam on all three different
surfaces
never wanted to play you might want to
go
out he also smoked a little crack right
he said he was on crack he did smoke a
little crack
i don't think that's true no he for sure
he was because i re i was a ball boy at
the u.s open all the all the jobs
all the jobs for like the queen's
dirtbag kid with me now he's on crowd
i swear to god he smoked crack so did
you smoke crap jennifer capriati smoke
crack too
i smoke crack with her so so when i was
a ball boy at the u.s
open and you know like everybody else
like wimbledon
and the french roland garros they'll all
get like elite kids like diplomats kids
to be the ball boys and ball girls and
court attendants
but queen in uh in the us open it's just
they get dirt bags from queens
so they went to you know my neighborhood
middle village ridgewood
glendale they just got all these kids
that were just you know
and we didn't understand really the
sport at all like we're just
cursing and we we're not being quiet
while they're volleying the ball back
forward
nobody [ __ ] knows we're like oh
tennis this is gay like we'd be like oh
we're watching this game
guys playing andre did not smoke crack
by the way uh he smoked crystal meth
crystal meth all right giannis how many
times
you smoke crack with jennifer capriati a
couple of times
it was about 90 the greatest if you said
once i'd be like you know why that was
because you can't keep your [ __ ]
mouth shut
are you spilling the beans on her uh
because you know i mean the
i that was like big news and then she
came back and she won the us open after
smoking crack i mean wait was it that
should be
smoked with you or big news that she
smoked no she i was just joking i never
smoked with her i didn't have the honor
i never had the honor of smoking with
her
um but i did have some friends who knew
who had the honor of smoking with her
true story
all right and yeah for a while i get
your podcast now okay true story here we
go
yeah yeah we just don't we don't tell
the truth at all
well yeah i mean we're we're just we're
two
gay kids trapped in straight bodies who
love history but don't talk about
history that's our podcast
that is definitely a unique niche but
the the
the thing i was saying with um
interesting it was [ __ ]
crazy with augustine with
so when we just said that augusty
yeah so so we
we um it's just fun it's a funny thing
because it's like listen it was 2001 so
you could just say
what you could say and it just wasn't a
problem but
you know 9 11 happened we were all court
attendants there and ball boys and you
know all my friends i'm still friends
with they they're all [ __ ] firemen
and cops now
but after it was augustine versus
sampras and there was an
in you know right after 9 11 when they
finished the us open
it was this insane rain storm so we had
to ground school we would have to clean
up the rain and do all that and
you know dry the courts and all that so
we were underneath the tunnel
while the zambonis were out there drying
and you know 9 11 it just happened and
agassi
asked that he was volleying they were
him and pete sampras were just vowing
the ball back and forth while me
and our you know all my other friends
that i'm still friends with are just
sitting down there we got nothing to do
and then they asked us andre agassi
asked us he was like what
did any of you guys anything happen to
any of your families in
in you know in the terrorist attack and
then he him and
pete sampras were sitting down on their
rackets listening to me
and my friend pat and a couple other
guys talk about
911 and all that and then one of my
friends he was like
cue andre agassi because it's just what
you know again it was 2001 we were 17.
he goes you're a good guy andre you he's
like we used to call you andre fogacy
but you're a pretty good guy and then
andre just laughed oh yeah he just
laughed he was like i've never heard
that one
and i was like you've probably heard
that one kid had a sick mullet for a
little while yeah and he used to wear
the dangling earring but he wasn't
wearing it that day and this is when he
was bald on dry augustine
it was pretty cool you got to read that
when he was starting to lose his hair he
had a little piece that he would wear
and he actually lost i think he lost a
big gay um
tournament because he was concerned he
was sweating so much that was going to
slide off his head
that's what he was dealing with it's
just like he can't seem to get that
first serve out of the net
and he was dealing with i'm telling you
dude it's it's a uh
it's an incredible um it's an incredible
reason as my listeners i'm gonna read it
i don't i don't think there's anything
funnier
um than a hairpiece right i don't think
there's anything
funnier than thinking of a guy taking
his his hair piece off and putting on a
statue next to his bed
and laying his self down to sleep i just
can't
imagine there's a couple of things one
how hot it is
i just would feel like it's wearing like
a woolen hat
all the time it's like that you're just
feeling your your scalp being sweaty
and then also god forbid if you're
single
and you're wearing a piece and you meet
some woman and you have feelings and you
can't have any secrets
at what point did you [ __ ] lift that
thing off
dude bill it happened to my father my
father
married my stepmom is still married to
this day had no idea
it was three weeks after they were
married she said i have something to
confess to you and she pulled her hair
off and she has a wig she's got a piece
she's got a piece i used to put her wig
on when i was a little kid and make
and do jump shots and call myself
grandma mock is what larry johnson can
write
she had one she pulled her hair off yeah
dude i'm telling you
nobody nobody knew and then i remember
my uncle my uncle who's dead now you
know i was [ __ ] horrible thing but he
just would do these things for laughs
because he's a psychopath
but i pull and it was horrible to even
think about this now but as an adult but
when i was a kid i was just doing what
my uncle said to do
i pulled her wig off on thanksgiving
dinner and ran down the block with it
that she's like a pioneer for women with
you told me to do that
it'll be funny it'll be funny what did
she oh she was mortified
mortified and you know was had you know
resentment towards me for
years that's just recently you know
opened up to kindness and love
since i had my kid now she's happy and
she forgot about it but i was
i didn't know i was a little kid i was
being told what to do she's got to be
some sort of pioneer for women
i didn't even know women would could
have a hairpiece yeah and it's a nice
thing it's a nice
it's sometimes you know my mom when they
would get an argument she'd bring it up
you know yeah she's just [ __ ] make
little jokes about your mom's
always got that over here yeah oh it's
brutal yeah
yeah that's why you can't you can't do
it you just kind of you gotta just
shave the head get [ __ ] for two weeks
and then people can't remember what you
look like with hair
and then it's over but you start you
know walking around [ __ ]
the skeleton even in the closet sitting
when did you
when did you just shave it bill how old
were you when you just shaved the head
how far back was the hair was the
hairline going how
how much was it fat joe's song lean back
before we like you know what let me just
give in to this
well that's a hip-hop reference so i
don't i remember that song
uh no i was losing it in the back
so i still have it in the front i don't
have it here so
so why don't you just go with the woody
allen with the little landing saucer
you could put a yamaka over it maybe
because i think he already has it he's
kind of done that look
true you look good now dude you look
like a [ __ ] emotional hitler stash i
mean you know
you got the right face for it i mean
what the [ __ ] i mean certain people just
you know i i don't want to but with that
guy's baggage i don't need to be rocking
haircut is him but if you you do have a
nice round head
like so it works out nice you look good
you're one of those guys who looked good
ball
but if you didn't if i didn't if i went
bald and my head wasn't as round as
yours i would try a piece
i would try to put it please
they do now is they bring in
reinforcements
as they're going so now they like vacuum
them out dude i know guys
who back in the day the option there was
before when i was a real little kid you
had those awful like ant legs that
literally you'd look at them and you saw
like that
dot they were [ __ ] horrible and then
um then they came up with a new thing
where they would cut like a uh like an
eighth inch
slice out of the back of your head
and then they would lay it on the
[ __ ] table
they'd stitch you back up this way and
then they would drop them in like that
not even knowing if they were gonna work
or not so that you'll see guys my age
still you'll see they have the smiley
face scar on the back of their head
that's from a transplant that didn't
take but now
you guys you spoiled millennials
they can just vacuum them out in the
back
no scar and then drop them in and you're
good to go and uh you know we're in show
business we've definitely seen people
losing a battle and all of a sudden
in the fourth quarter they came back and
won and one big
um and they and it looks great too i'm
just
uh i'm just not into it like i guess i
could do that but
um i i i don't i like
i guess if you if you look like brad
pitt i get why doing it but like why
would i do all of that like i feel like
if you look like me
the more you look like a regular guy the
better chance you have
at getting work you know yeah like i'm
gonna get hair plugs at 52 and what be
the next [ __ ] heartthrob
i'm 52. it's [ __ ] over right it's
over either way so
did you did they did when
when you went into the role in the
appetite movie about pete
did they did they at some point want to
put a rug on you you just went with
with the bald look no no
if anything they were like what if we
grow it out i was gonna do that
um i kind of look at my head like a
blank slate
so like whatever whatever you want to do
with it i don't give a [ __ ]
but like i'm not gonna uh you know
acting is one thing
all right but like you're in a movie
whatever you got to look a certain way
whatever you know
but like uh as far as my day-to-day
like i'm not dealing with gluing some
[ __ ] on my head
or taking some [ __ ] that's keeping my
hair going but it's crushing my liver
so i'll dye it like 58 with a nice
[ __ ] you know healthy head of hair
nice you know
like a damaged liver you're the best you
ever looked you're the best you ever
looked
now you just guys just get the [ __ ]
facial hair with the bald look that's
your look
because when you're in your late 30s you
had kind of your hair was it was
receding haley wearing [ __ ]
bell-bottom jeans
you were going out you're out of your
[ __ ] mind i was like this guy's the
funniest guy i've ever seen he looks
like a [ __ ] idiot
but why has he got stars on his
shoulders it was baggy clothes
and we all wore them and you wore them
too i know i'm just kidding i'm just i
could see you shaking i'm just kidding
i can tell you i can tell you this well
i mean i i
you know you give me [ __ ] i give it give
it back that's that's the game
yeah dude i'll take all the [ __ ] i'm not
asking you to i'm just telling you what
i'm gonna do
i i actually uh unfortunately had a
friend of mine
passed away the past month so i went
back to look at photos to see what i had
you know for the memorial and all of
that
and i have to tell you as much [ __ ] as
the 70s get
for clothes the 90s are the worst
and what kills me is i had like
a [ __ ] eight-pack stomach i was
shredded i
i was just and you didn't show it off
and i was wearing like potato sacks
like dude this right here this little
seam here that's supposed to be like
right here on your shoulder
was like almost down by my elbow yeah
it was just it was the whole [ __ ]
everybody looks like they used to be 300
pounds
and did some fad diet and lost like a
buck 80.
um you got the guns going we all see him
chrissy
say again i saw your flex in there on
that take there check it out yeah
you don't know you know what happened i
got it cries are popping dude you're
crushing it
i gotta chill through the air
conditioner and it maybe floats up but
then i did look out i looked tried to
look at my tattoo which looks like [ __ ]
what is what does it say uh scripture
this one this one's my name my
neighborhood on my arm it says
established in 1984 the year was born
stupid
then i have scripture on my arm i got a
cross on my back i
look like i'm fighting in a [ __ ]
catholic crusade that doesn't exist yeah
he looks like robert de niro from cape
fear
yeah it's stupid he's got he's got like
[ __ ] scriptures all over
guys you guys are really big on your
neighborhoods
yeah we love the neighborhoods and we i
moved out of it immediately and what's
funny is
is all it is is nothing but horrific
stories about how shitty it was and what
happened
but like everybody i i respect that yeah
of the the uh dysfunction you guys are
the the bay ridge boys
now we're the bay ridge boys yeah
british boys we made it even more local
we got into show business
to make it go even more local yeah like
what can we think of the most obscure
neighborhood to call ourselves
how about bay ridge brooklyn there you
go
bill did your friend who passed away did
he pass away from covid
no no that's it sucks to die during a
pandemic of something else that's not
the disease
it's like dying on 9 11 but you [ __ ]
weren't in the bill you got hit by a car
yeah yeah you don't you definitely don't
get the big press release
uh yeah no what it is is uh
without getting totally in the deal into
the deal it's just when uh
you know you start paying for your sins
i get it yeah i would suggest all of you
guys especially you giannis
i don't know you're sort of sitting
there sagging with that depressed look
on your face you got a lot of weight
a lot of weight between your ears i
would definitely go to a heart
and between his tits lately i've gotten
really fat recently bill
you know i just you have such an amazing
ah [ __ ] i can't hear you i can't hear
you what happened we'll i will
it'll come back it'll come back hello
can you hear me now
yeah i missed that you were talking
about i just know that i just know from
when i follow you on twitter that the
bruins won last night
no they didn't they lost they got
bounced out so you should be happy
that's a that's a boston team that
didn't win a championship
but you know what that's what we have in
common as boston
and new york guys as northeast corridor
guys where we're from is a big part of
who we are
and that you tweet about boston sports
being a
national in a lot of ways international
comedian also shows that you're as
[ __ ] stupid as we are
yeah i mean well i don't get moving
somewhere else and then just being like
well you know
i need a local team here what's your
heart
what's hard for me is that when i moved
to new york
it was like the height of the curse of
the babe thing and then i come out to
l.a and it's always celtics lakers and
[ __ ] like that and uh
you know and then with the whole astros
scandal and then the guy was coaching
the red sox we beat the dodgers it just
becomes like this
i've just been behind sports enemy lines
for so long that recently when i went to
a bruins home game
i i just couldn't believe that i i could
wear a bruins teeth
shirt and not have to have it zipped up
and have to i just you know i'm too
[ __ ] old
to be dealing with people yelling at me
and [ __ ] like i usually just go like
plain clothes i just
show up quietly root for my team and i
leave
but um i am envious that the fact that
you guys got to be in show business
stay where you're from and um
you know still be able to go to the
teams you want to see but that's also
why new yorkers are such
meatheads is you guys never leave
and your perspective of the world is
like literally 20 blocks
yeah it's just like oh look at the
skyline look at oh this is amazing
and then when you go elsewhere you act
like you're not uncomfortable you act
like it's just a piece of [ __ ] and
you're above it but the reality is
the second you guys get away from your
favorite place to buy your kicks and
your [ __ ] pizza
yeah you get horrifically uncomfortable
no i lost
okay i love going to la i appreciate the
sights now i roll around in california i
go
to the left over here we got a fire
that's on fire
over there so that whole block material
giannis
is on fire over here those mexicans
right there
they're they're working over there for
less than a minimum wage
over there uh there's water being piped
in
from another state over there this place
shouldn't be here
well none of you should be here we stole
the country giannis
i know what about new york you can't do
that in new york
i i hang out with you in new york you
know you're like over here i got shot
this is where i saw a homeless guy take
a [ __ ] and you want to talk about
illegal aliens you don't have any of
those in new york
that's why i got out of there and that's
why i'm living in new hampshire now
and country away from you man they're
taking my goddamn country you're not
gonna do it i got myself a gun i'm a gun
owner
come and get some anything comes up that
hill i'm shooting it
yeah no yeah dude but sports there's
trust in sports though like no i bought
a gun i bought a gun
i own a gun i know and you're so yes you
got such a
[ __ ] diarrhea of the mouth when you
buy a gun the last thing you do is go on
the podcast and let people know
that when they go in there at your house
that they need to be strapped to
yeah you just literally read your
playbook you dummy
yeah well you know what nobody knows
where i live because i live in new
hampshire so
come get some if you want some come get
some
all right yeah i'm just going to stay
i'm in brooklyn in the [ __ ] thick of
it
and there's a part of me that wants to
go but now i don't know i may there's
it's like
should i go just go down with the ship
but that's stupid too
right bill because it's like that's what
i'm doing in l.a
you're going down with the ship you're
not going to move to austin like
everybody
like half of my friends at this point
have either died
got canceled or are now leaving la
so i'm just feeling like i feel like a
fifth year senior in high school right
now like
like where did everybody go so it's been
um
yeah it's been a definitely uh
definitely weird definitely weird i've
been fighting off
uh having the blues i wouldn't quite
help depression but i definitely
have been fighting that type of [ __ ] off
so i've been trying to throw myself
into other things i got some socially
distant
shows coming out um how was how was
going to dave chappelle's thing
oh man it was incredible and um heard
you made a lot of money
uh oh yeah man hand over fist i bought
the next town over from dave
um i basically uh no dude he [ __ ]
flew us all in
it was like a paid vacation and then i
got to do [ __ ]
um i got to do stand-up the way it used
to be
everybody's phones were locked and there
was this oh my god i can say whatever i
want to say
and i don't have to deal with white
chicks trying to end my [ __ ] career
or or just the idea of it um which i'm
really hoping the same way
90s clothes went out of style that
when all of this is over this whole um
sort of comedy um what was that thing
uh mccarthyism that they're doing and
the way people
like the the amount of [ __ ] comedians
that are are just co-signing on
accusations
when it's like it might happen might not
have happened
and they're like trying to help take out
these guys
is uh it was pretty eye-opening
and then it's weird when you run into
one of those comics and you know that
they're the ones that
will just go with what anything is said
and then they say hello to you and you
just kind of look at
them like uh hi until somebody says 20
years ago i
sneezed on their [ __ ] burrito or some
[ __ ] and then
then you're it's like i know who you are
i know what you
you're gonna do so i i just find the
whole thing it's just such a bizarre
bizarre [ __ ] time you know yeah
there's no comedy community now it's
you everyone's your potential enemy
there is 95
of comics are not doing that and um
i i just really think it just says a lot
to me about a person
you know because a lot of the times too
it's not just like look obviously
if somebody has like [ __ ] you know 30
women coming out
okay i know the person still didn't get
a trial
but i mean it's like what the [ __ ] how
did you get 30 people to all
have roughly the same story like i get
all of that but like
my thing is was when they then delve
into it my favorite thing is
then you see them just slowly start
criticizing the comedians
act and all of this [ __ ] you start to be
like oh wait a minute now let's let's
try to stay on
uh let's try to keep it on the road here
remember what you're outraged about
you're outraged about these uh alleged
victims you're not outraged about how
this person was getting more spots than
you were
at the [ __ ] chuckle hut so it's
definitely um
it's yeah it seems like so you just have
to you just have to say
hi back and because it's because it's
you know air quote not worth it
but i mean it's it's hard from for uh
i don't know i mean i don't like to live
my life not saying what i'm feeling
so but it's it is it is what it is as
they say isn't that you're irish though
isn't kind of
that what you guys do isn't that y'all's
deal i'm mostly german well it was a
german kid like me
a lot of movies about irish people
i don't know what irish people are like
because uh
i'm mixed with a bunch of different euro
white european [ __ ] so i would
i would go to ireland to find out what
they're like but
um you know german and irish yeah you
guys are you guys aren't as
that effusive with your emotions it's
more more cerebral
i know and you guys have big fat greek
weddings i also watch hollywood movies
about your [ __ ] you know
did you not you didn't you didn't uh
educate yourself through library
fees at the at the library and take a
janitor job at harvard
just to be around those people but
scurry off when someone wants to know
who did that equation on the wall that's
not you
oh boy first the la fires and now a
[ __ ] goodwill hunting reference
yeah we're going wild here today look
bill if you're depressed when you come
to do your show in connecticut
can you please meet up with us because
we are the cure for depression
we will [ __ ] take you on a ferry ride
we will [ __ ]
set sail with you we'll take you to some
museums we'll prance around get some
[ __ ] ice cream
and get [ __ ] cute and drink some
smoothies and put a smile on that sour
face
i would do that in a second but giannis
i know you after the smoothie and the
sugar rush
ends i know as as chris says yoni long
days comes in
yeah now we call johnny biden because he
keeps forgetting what he's saying
one of my favorite clips i saw of your
show which i absolutely [ __ ] love i
think you guys are superstars man people
watching this you gotta check these guys
out
um i was watching uh this clip
some guy talking about covet and he was
talking about the things
bad things that were happening and
giannis was just stoking the fires guys
like
well you know there's gonna be hospital
beds filled there's gonna be a blah blah
blah and then giannis just goes
riding in the streets and the guys like
rioting in the streets
and i literally i swipe past it it's
like i don't want to [ __ ] listen to
this [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know i hate that i'm right
so much
i avoid um
that train of thought because i know how
i'm wired and i'm paranoid and i i can't
listen
to that [ __ ] the same way like i avoid
a lot of discussions with parents when
they they get into that hysteria
like have you got your kid into a
private school yet you got to do this
are they doing puzzles if they're not
doing puzzles
people are saying blah blah i just
[ __ ] i just walk away
so yeah yeah yeah same with me i don't
go on the ride
i get the smoothie i give
i'd give chrissy the nod and then i
would slowly just back away
and i don't even give a [ __ ] what subway
line it was on and which way it was
going i'd go down those stairs and i
would get on it
and then just i would get away from you
yeah well if you don't think we're gonna
make you
take us a sip with the straw and yell
cute while you do it
yeah we're gonna do it yeah and if you
don't think we're gonna secretly film it
and put it on patreon.comridgeboys
you got another thing coming it's about
the content baby
yeah that's it that's it you got another
thing cummins one of my favorite
uh yeah thank you yeah man you got
another thing coming that's a [ __ ]
old school that ended every if this guy
thinks
is basically if this guy thinks he's
gonna be doing exactly what i'm letting
him get away with he's got another thing
coming it's like
he's thinking that because you're
letting him do that that's that's
basically that
that uh the phony tough talk after the
fact when i was a kid
uh bill i got a i got a daughter coming
uh she's due in the
uh beginning of october any tips for me
um no man it's other than it's
it's kind of a great thing that it's
it's it's happening during the pandemic
is great
because you won't be going on the road
or anything you can be there
for everything having a kid is one of
the few things that lives up to the hype
it's it's it's great i would just my
only advice is
is really be careful who you listen to
when it comes to other parents
because uh anybody can have a kid
and i've just sort of found that if
parents have a kid older than yours
they think they know everything and
whatever their kid's doing
you're gonna do so what i learned from
that is i'm not gonna give you any
advice
because what do i know i've only been
doing it for a couple of years so i just
i'm really happy for you and you're
gonna have a great time and like i said
just watch out
you know if you feel your heart rate
coming up talking to somebody just
get away from that includes [ __ ]
doctors too you'll take them oh this
baby's underweight this baby's
overweight they don't take into
consideration
the build of your family yeah genetics
and all of that type of [ __ ] like you
know
it's just they're also sponsored too
like doctors i don't you know it's like
doc a lot of doctors like those
companies drugs and
these vaccines that they're all
sponsoring they're paying them they're
giving them kickbacks so you have to
just be
you have to do your own research and now
with the internet it's like i just do
all my own research as much as i can
try to work collaboratively with the
pediatrician but i'm also like yeah i'm
not just going to give my kid this
medication
if her [ __ ] test is coming up
negative for strep throat but you just
want to give her the antibiotics anyway
it's like no i'm not gonna do that we've
got to believe it i definitely
i definitely got my kid like all the
vaccinations oh yeah no
i did too i'm saying like antibiotics or
different things where it's like
some of that stuff is not always
necessary
yeah it's it's it's an ugly game it's an
ugly ugly game baby i heard that when
they bring their new drugs there
they have good-looking people bring it
to the doctors and the doctors get a
little bump
you know of course they bring a little
hottie in there
of course sales guys i don't know if
you've ever heard that yes it's big time
yeah big time which is why you guys are
so successful
i mean we're we're a couple of cute kids
without a doubt without a doubt
what are you guys gonna do your gay
straight show podcast
live at uh at one of the local gay clubs
that's actually a good look we have the
largest
transgendered fan base in any podcast
that has been
absolutely looked into and researched
we're number one we have the most trans
fans
yep so that's a great idea to perform
for that very important subset of our
fan base yeah
we would actually have a [ __ ] great
show together why can't we just say that
now like
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah i [ __ ] feel like i'm trans today
what like like am i a bad person now if
i'm like hey today i feel trans and
that's what i want to go with
but then tomorrow i don't are you
shaming me by telling me
hey yesterday you wanted to be transit
today you don't like i just feel like
everything's a [ __ ] free-for-all now
on what you can and can't say it's like
yeah you know what today with bill burr
i wanted to go trans and that's i felt
right and maybe tomorrow i won't
no listen no nobody's saying you can't
go trans i don't know i don't know where
that came from
well all right i'm gonna go cut my dick
off
he's he just doesn't want to do it while
his father's alive he's waiting for his
father to pass
and then i think he's going full chris
that's the thing dude and also the
problem is you got your your protruding
brow is going to be tough
yeah i've never been able to take a good
look inside if i'm really being honest
with myself
on who who i am as a man and my
sexuality is because my dad's still
alive and he just
there's something it's a block but when
he dies i may come right out
i don't [ __ ] know yeah i mean you
make a beautiful handsome man but as a
woman it's a little
scary huh they can shave that brow down
if they don't think that they can make
people's like if they got the big
lantern job
they can fix that they i got that i got
that frankenstein thing too
yeah no i'm actually i'm i know i i i'm
not gay i know i'm not gay and late i
haven't had sex
with with anyone in five four five
months and that feels good too i
realized like
you know i was just a sexually sexual
sex maniac for a while but now i'm
better the ladies
love this kid big time i've heard the
stories the stories made it all the way
out here
yeah i mean i mean big big man he was in
demand here's the thing
chris says that he falls in love with
man he has sex with women now
we couldn't wait to get out this podcast
because you seem like a real comfortable
person
to talk to this to talk to about this
what do you think what's his perspective
see you mugging at chris when you said
that
no because you're kind of a flu you're
you're you're kind of a fluid guy you're
not really
you're fluid so it's like what does that
mean that chris likes to he falls in
love with men but he has sex with women
what's your take on that as an
open-minded kid from boston
i'm gonna get yelled at i'm gonna drag
boston into it i knew i was gonna get
yelled at because i wanted to get yelled
at
i want to get scolded i got a fetish for
it
um what does that mean well i'm not a
sex therapist
i don't know that could mean anything
from his unresolved issues with his dad
all the way to like he's getting like i
i think just you know i gotta be on i
just think they stick everything in a
box it's like either you're an addict
you're not
you're gay right you're [ __ ] uh
i don't know what else i ran you know
what though you know you know like drug
addicts find each other
sex addicts find each other too i
noticed that and i went
and i when i i went to like two meetings
to like you know like
try to go through it and talk about it
and i notice it's all
dangerous to have all you guys in the
same room you just didn't all start
[ __ ] on the table
yeah just all no it's not it's weird
it's not like that it i
thought that that's what it was gonna be
but it's really not like that at all
yeah no i just went
i started [ __ ] cranking because it
must be like a lot of good looking
people in there right if you haven't no
it wasn't
it wasn't there was there was one guy
who's like 85 years old
then there was uh there was one person
who was uh transgender
uh there was a couple of girls in there
it was mostly guys
and then and uh and yeah it's weird
because it's like we just
we all it was all it was always empty
sex on both sides like i would imagine
like you know people go do coke or
[ __ ] addicted to crack or whatever
they just do it and then that's it
and then it's like ugh get away from me
but it's been nice for the past few
months to be like ugh
have some clarity on i didn't realize
how much my mind was being clouded by
just trying to chase [ __ ] all the time
so you think now you're [ __ ] up a lot
of time
and giannis thank you for once again
perpetuating the myth
that all racism in this country exists
in the south and in boston
you won't you say that did i say that he
kind of did he goes you open-minded
boston guy
it's just oh yeah i meant that in the
sort of a way that
you you're you're a guy's guy bill for
sure you're a guy's guy
you're you're projecting it's you're
you're not dirty i'm not a guy's guy i i
look like a [ __ ]
uh pumpkin yeah please
let's just be careful barbaro man the
marlboro man the
guy's guy has jet black hair or brown
hair
a strong [ __ ] jaw he has pigment
i mean that that's that's hollywood's
guy's guy all right
yeah but i mean if i came to you with
the problem and it wasn't like a real
real problem but i just needed to talk
to my emotions
about my emotions i think there's a
chance you would tell me to just suck it
up
and and work harder okay well yeah i
mean listen there's
there's who i am and who you think i am
yeah there it is there it is yeah i'm
gonna
no matter what bill i'm the one who's
gonna get yelled at after this [ __ ]
episode
so because last time i chimed in and you
guys were arguing
he was [ __ ] screaming at me so i
don't know what to say now
i was just i'm on the [ __ ] other
greek side i want to do start doing a
podcast with this greek
who's it the producer kid yeah [ __ ]
mark phillips's
yeah you can well if you can keep your
feelings professional i think you guys
could do a lot of stuff in this
i can't keep my feelings professionally
with that [ __ ] beautiful hair that
kid's got a
a head of beautiful hair and it's it's
it's pulled back
and it's turning me on and he's a greek
kid so for me and him
it's quite natural you guys you don't
have that in your culture as much as we
do
but look i'm not saying i'm a gay kid
but if i went to if i went to jail i'd
be
i'd be pretty good at it giannis you're
an american and you're from new york
city
so yeah stop with all the [ __ ] old
country horseshit
you you were 100 of this country
you're out of this soil that that's
that's what you are
i am i am i yeah i am you're searching
for an identity and i can tell you right
now
you don't get that fat eating greek food
can you see that you are eating american
poison that is what you are eating yeah
i got to get my tea man you got you got
maybe a d
cup going there yeah coming to the stage
like a gentleman and i'm telling them
it's going to get
it's it i could go one of two ways when
the baby's born either something will
kick in
his genetic coding will kick in and say
i gotta lose the weight for
this baby and and do this and that or
it's just he's gonna be so exhausted
especially those first couple years that
i mean we get into a
real i mean i'm talking about a 400
pound
situation where i'm just gonna [ __ ]
slap bacon off his tits
on the patreon all day yeah
yeah i've got real definitely has the
potential
to become a big boy you see him he's
he's one of those
in shape guys but you can also see you
can see the fatty within
i'm going breakfast club on you now yeah
i mean ask versi how i eat he actually
says he's
actually cannot believe that i have not
blown out fully by the way i eat
he's actually said that i sometimes put
on displays that rival
like bobby kelly displays of eating i'll
tell you
your [ __ ] version can throw down he
can yeah
and not only that that guy can throw
down whenever you want early
late doesn't you know double up little
double header that guy can he
that guy can throw down he can i'm
smoking sticks every day by the way
since it's pandemic you think that's a
problem
i am so envious of that although i have
found though when you do it every day
like you so burn out your taste buds
then you're just doing it to be doing it
so i try to uh i try to like
go like two weeks but i gotta tell you
man the anticipation after two weeks is
just
it's tremendous when you kind of do it
day in and day out when i went out when
i went out and did chappelles
i just said [ __ ] it and i brought like
four or five with me you know had the
little nubs for during the day
like one of my favorite things to do on
the road is to do laundry
i just hate coming home with like
[ __ ] dirty underwear and
socks and all that [ __ ] so dude only the
hall if only the hall of fame
white guys are going to dave chappelle's
camp you
ck john stewart you got to be hall of
fame
white if you want to get invited to
chappelle yeah not middle of road white
ain't getting that [ __ ] call babe
it's the big league whites
and listen we deserve it i'm not mad at
fort it's like yeah what the [ __ ]
i get it what did i never do for you
yeah i think adam ray went he's hall of
fame totally adam right yeah
hall of fame yeah dude i'll tell you
adam ray i did
i did a roast you would have loved this
giannis
i did a roast a big poppy uh
in boston uh and adam ray was on it
and dude he hired a makeup person
and he came out in character as this guy
like 20 years older than him
bald wearing like a yankees jersey
and he came up as a yankee fan and just
trashed the [ __ ] red sox
all of their fans in all of boston he
[ __ ]
murdered we loved it he we love it he
was like
we got 27 you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
everything that he said
everything that you would say to me that
would get me going
to argue he said but it was hilarious
because it was at a roast and everybody
just knew that that's what it was and um
dude i'm telling you i have like and he
also was on um
uh joe mcintyre show returning the mac
and he crushed it on that he's a super
super talented guy dude
i filmed i hosted the show once it was
called off the bat
it was like on mtv2 but it was major
league baseball's attempt
to make baseball like young and cool or
whatever and big poppy was the producer
and we were in this is [ __ ] we were it
was me a camera guy and big poppy
and he stops the interview in the back
of his suv he stops the interview
and he gets on the he's like guys please
turn the cameras off gets on the phone
with his agent
and it was when the red sox wouldn't
sign him to a one-year deal
to be the highest paid dh in the league
and he says i've had
enough of this [ __ ] he's telling his
agent right in front of all but it's
like i had a [ __ ] up for this [ __ ]
he said if they don't give me the deal i
want in one hour he said call brian
cashman and
i'm signing with the yankees he said
this in front of us all right i remember
you told me the story you said
true story i i'm texting i text my
father
i'm like dad biggest you guys you can't
keep your mouth shut
it's a true story listen cause i text my
dad i'm like biggest [ __ ] news of all
time i said dad
i think poppy's coming to the yanks
gonna be big big news i'll explain when
i get home
so then i forget i even texted my father
my dad just
takes me out my word of course they
brian
that call never happens red big poppy
becomes the highest paid dh
in the league they red such won the
world series that year i get a call from
my stepmother the next
uh i get a call from my stepmother maybe
a day or two
later she goes what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and i'm like what are you
talking about
she goes your father just put five
thousand dollars on the yankees to win
the world series
because he said big poppy's gonna be
their dh but i saw his on the red sox
yankees came in third in the at least
that yeah and i got yelled at by my
stepmom almost every day of the season
every time the yankees lost she was like
really this is what you do to us
christopher
exactly i got to do a little i got to do
a little advertising
here thanks for having us bill
appreciate it
soon um your yankees by the way you win
the dodgers a favor
odds on favorite to win the world series
and we both know how that's gonna go
yeah don't tell my father that because
i'll lose another 5k
we both know the dodgers can't they
can't swing that leg over the fence they
can't get over the hump
all right i cannot see you guys later
thank you so much uh
giannis papas christie
dana do you have any uh stand updates
you said yes
it cut out if it wouldn't freeze
do you have any stand updates that you
want to
uh yes yeah we historyhyenas.com um we
could check out all our stand up dates
there
i i'm on the road october 8th to the
11th
um in uh delaware scranton pa pittsburgh
pa
and cape cod massachusetts with andrew
santino and then uh
october 23rd i got a live streaming show
at 8pm
anywhere in the world any state any city
live streaming
for an hour uh october 23rd
christiecomedy.com for tickets
yeah and i'll be at the stress factory
my only show before my daughter's born
october 1st to the 3rd in new brunswick
new jersey uh
you can get tickets
giannispappiscomedy.com and please go
check out my special
blowing the light on youtube uh it's
free
enjoy it hopefully and uh of course just
follow us history yeah
historians and also patreon.com bay
ridge boys where we go really uncensored
behind the paywall and it's comedy like
the old days
as bill was saying when we go out of our
[ __ ] minds patreon.com
bay ridge boys yeah pre pre white chick
influence
on stand up uh there you go there you go
all right guys thank you so much
i hope to see you soon when this [ __ ] is
over
thanks bill thanks bill if you're over
here man hit us up all right sorry about
the background change just was having uh
a little what did he call glitch here
all right look who's here everybody
hymns uh 66 percent of men start losing
their hair by age 35.
um once you've noticed thing here it can
be too late
why do guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing when they can turn
to medicine and science solution
for hims.com a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care
sexual wellness for men it's time to
write a new chapter
one which you have hair prescription
solutions backed by science
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health conversations
are easier to have online than in person
no more awkward in person uh my hair's
falling out my dick doesn't work
none of that [ __ ] all right uh you can
do it online answer a few quick
questions a medical professional will
review
and they'll determine if it's right for
you and then they can prescribe you
medications to treat hair loss
that is shipped directly to your door
today
hymns is giving you their best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now my listeners
can get their first visit free and go uh
by going to for hims.com
bird b-u-r-r-e-d that's for him
f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash
bird uh okay full refund of price paid
available for first 90 days supply
refund request uh must be made between
90 and 180 days after the product
shipment is delivered
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety information
remember
that's for hims.com bird
um all right simply safe everyone
here's the thing about home security
companies most trap you with high prices
tricky contracts and lousy customer
support
so while there are a lot of options out
there there's only one no-brainer simply
safe simply safe got everything you need
to promote your home
with your non with none of the drawbacks
of traditional home
security uh it's got an arsenal of
sensors and cameras to
blanket every room uh window and door
tailored specifically
for your home uh professional monitoring
keep
keeps watch day and night ready to send
police fire or medical professionals if
there's any emergency
uh you can set it up yourself in under
an hour just
peel and stick the sensors exactly where
you need them to be
no technician required and there's no
contract no pushy sales guys no hidden
fees no fine print
um all this starts at just at fit just
just 15 bucks a month
i'm not the only one who thinks simply
safe is great us news and world report
named it the best overall home security
of 2020.
try simply save today at
simplysafeburr.com
you get free shipping and a 60 day risk
free trial there's nothing to lose
that's simplysafeburr.com
and uh what do we got here oh
cbdmd cbd
uh this is for all the people out there
man
with joint pain it doesn't matter if
you're a professional athlete a
stay-at-home parent or you spend eight
hours a day in an uncomfortable office
chair
everyone needs support to make it
through the day luckily our friends at
cbdmd
uh have an amazing duo of topical
products that can help you relax regroup
and recharge when life gets chaotic
cbd freeze and with
menthol is an award-winning product that
off
offers instant cooling relief for
muscles and joints
in a convenient and easy to use roller
or shareable squeeze tube i use this
[ __ ] this stuff is great
cbd recover combines cbd with
inflammation fighting compounds like
arnica and and vitamin b6 to give you
support you need where it matters most
and to make it even easier uh to try
this
amazing duo of topicals and everything
else cbd cbdmd is off
has to offer they're offering all my
listeners 20 off your next order at
cbdmd.com
when you use the promo code burr burr at
checkout once again that's cbdmd.com
promo code bird for 20 off your purchase
of superior cbd
oil products from cbdmd
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr hola
me amigos
donde es un pero de la mesa
sorry i'm back into the [ __ ] rosetta
stone spanish what's going on it's bill
burr
it's the monday morning podcast for uh
september dos
dos e uno i've been listening to uh
oh by the way before i get before before
i get going
um today's show is brought to you by
audible.com
slash bill is that what i'm supposed to
say no today's show is brought to you by
audible please visit
audible.com bill for your free
audiobook download all right
would you like to go to a party with an
ascot on and sound like you're well read
even if you don't read
does reading make you sleepy but for
some reason somebody else's voice is
in your head reading a book makes you
feel like you're being held
well i have the solution for you go to
audible.com slash bill and get your free
audio download book
when you listen to spanish radio right
whatever you call latino
puerto rico whatever you're supposed to
uh miramira whatever the [ __ ] you're
supposed to say
you know you're just trying to pick up
words right so all i do now
is i just listen to the uh you know am
radio of course
you know white people are all
are on fm latinos and
like [ __ ] psycho-political people in
sports
are all on am radio religious people
you know what i mean like if you're just
on fm radio and you're going up and down
the dial and whatever like you're living
in a completely different universe
if you switch over to am radio
you know it's it's uh you know you can
literally listen to like some game in
alaska in alaska you can
next channel there's somebody talking
about jesus
and then jesus said to the episcopalians
in john 3.65
you know that um gay people are all
going to hell whatever the [ __ ] they're
talking about right
and then you get over to the spanish
station you try to [ __ ] listen you're
supposed to immerse yourself
in the language and uh
it's starting to happen i can actually
hear different words i don't know what
the [ __ ] they mean but it's slowly but
surely happening
and i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about unless
it's like a word like that's just
totally
like the english word with like an o at
the end muy importento
and you're like very important
[Laughter]
but always in the end always in the end
when they give out the phone number i
know what they're saying
[Music]
um anyways
and they say they say pero pero aora
that's now i order let's get down to
brass tacks this is the monday morning
podcast
me amigos and me and me guys um
i got a lot of [ __ ] going on you know
you know what's weird the last few weeks
when i do the podcast i do it downstairs
my [ __ ] dog
looks like it got shot with the
tranquilizer gun
just [ __ ] lays here mocking you know
you know i i literally i feel like i'm
bombing
because in reality the dog is my only
audience and
you know i'm gonna take a [ __ ]
picture of her right now
you know what and we're gonna upload it
i've never shown you guys a picture you
know what's great about this
you guys have never seen what my dog
looks like and now i'm gonna send you a
picture
and all the dog people like oh my god
yeah he's finally gonna do it
well here's the thing you're not gonna
see her face
it's gonna be like people magazine when
they used to try to get a picture of uh
let me just try to get a picture like
paul stanley
from kiss you know that yet another
horrific group from detroit
what is wrong with white music from
detroit they got the black
[ __ ] down so well motown all those guys
right through marvin gaye who i guess
was a motown artist but
um but jesus christ they're white music
other than eminem
that is a [ __ ] mess out there huh the
bay city royal
rollers remember them they just sing
about
saturday nights little coke spoons
hanging around twisted up in their chest
hair wasn't that that gig
um who else ted nugent
cat scratch fever
all right throw him on the [ __ ] trash
heap um
kiss who else is from there
kid rock you know
you should melt all of those people down
and then [ __ ] reform them into maybe
like a
a coffeehouse musician
you know bill you got a lot of [ __ ]
nerve man how many [ __ ] albums you
sold oh go [ __ ] yourself i got a goddamn
hour to fill here okay
kid rock always walk around with no
shirt on and a budweiser we get it
you're down to earth
oh was there paparazzi here as i stepped
out of my limo with my bud tall
did your publicist [ __ ] open that for
you
there you go bill trash somebody who was
relevant in 99.
all right have you ever been relevant
bill see that
that's why i i like to think that i'm
even-handed because as i trash other
people i also trash myself
don't i maybe not um
anyways let's shut off the [ __ ]
goddamn camera you know i keep playing
on my iphone i keep playing ice rage
you guys play that hockey game i play at
the hottest level
and i had this [ __ ] be like i
just refused to play any other level at
this point
other than the hardest level and
a at this point i am one in about 260.
that's my record and the only time i won
the first time was because i did
this [ __ ] move where i got two goals
right in the beginning and then one
another face-off
and then just [ __ ] skated with the
puck for like a minute
killing the clock just skating around
getting chased by that little
[ __ ]
right so yesterday i'm like i'm gonna
beat this dude fair
and square and um
singing sweet home alabama in the
morning
who downloaded that
i mean gee how many [ __ ] hit songs do
you gotta [ __ ] slam together
and then you get a hit song out of it it
doesn't [ __ ] make any sense
you know you got the whole the uh where
wolves of london you're coming out of
the gate with that
bump
[Music]
right hey we just swiped a hit song
what do you think i don't think that's
enough
why don't we swipe another one and we'll
put that in the chorus
singing sweet home alabama cheryl crow's
tits
um isn't that what happened she put her
tits in the camera and then they that
you know what it is
that's that i think is actually a
product
of everybody stealing music and there's
no more music stores so this is when and
let me i'm wrong maybe i owe kid rock an
apology like this is what
this this is the level of [ __ ] hoops
this dude has to jump through
in in order to have a [ __ ] hit record
how do you get your music out that's the
amazing thing about lady gaga
right the new queen uh queen of uh the
gay community
you know they always love chicks like
that who played like dress up and wear
crazy hats
you know pulled down over their beak
noses i don't know what it is but gay
people
they can't get enough of chicks like
that right
but i was sitting there looking at lady
gaga going what the [ __ ] is she doing
and now i get it
there's no there's no radio
that's another spanish word for you it's
not radio you just roll the radio
see now i'm speaking spanish now i'm
back to english look at me huh i'm
[ __ ] crossing you over in a verbal
way
breaking your [ __ ] ankles um
i'm such a douche this week all right so
don't even send me emails about what a
douche i am because i'm completely aware
of it
okay i don't know if that makes me more
of a douche
or more tolerable but i'm just letting
you know where it's at
cleo didn't even move
didn't even [ __ ] move you know i get
her to move while i go is
do you wanna
and there goes the tail cleo do you
wanna
[ __ ] dog's like yeah i wanna i don't
have a [ __ ] driver's license i can't
open the front door
you know maybe my dog isn't happy maybe
it's [ __ ] depressed
hey what's the point man all i'm going
to do is walk in another room with
nothing to do
i'm just going to lay here all day um
the [ __ ] was i talking about i was on a
nice roll there oh yeah there's no
[ __ ]
there's no radio there's no [ __ ] mtv
doesn't play videos anymore nobody buys
your music how the [ __ ] do you get your
music out there
you got to put on a meat dress so then
all that guy that guy there there with
his little sippy cup on that
paparazzi show will be i'll just say
this tonight she had on a [ __ ] meat
dress
that's not making the show um anyways
people
you know what i'm gonna start actually
uh am i gonna use audible.com
can i use it audible.com can i go use
that and then
[ __ ] what books would i get you know
when i when i used to read when i was
27 and i thought i was gonna be smart
i started reading books thinking it
would make me
more likely to get a [ __ ] but it
never
[ __ ] happened um
because i looked like ron howard when i
was
27. i'm so anyways now i'm 44.
um
if i was gonna have uh books read to me
i would do the the irvine welsh
series you know because i'm a big fan of
that that [ __ ]
what is it cockney accent [ __ ] irish
spring let me cut into some soap with a
with a shank
accent and there was a bunch of words in
there that i kind of figured out because
he literally writes it how they say it
and uh maybe if i you know i wonder if
they actually have like somebody
you know who's if you're gonna do the
urban welsh series of books
on audible.com bill trying to fill my
contractual obligations with these
people i'm trying to say it as many
times as humans but i actually like
these guys
you know considering there's no there's
no more bookstores anymore
these guys are actually picking up the
slack right
i like audible.com bill you know what i
don't like i'm i'm not doing the pro
flowers thing anymore
okay i like those guys but i like them
on valentine's day and
mother's day other than that i can't sit
here with any sort of good conscience
and try and sell you guys flowers in the
beginning of [ __ ] september
what are you gonna get so many flowers
for [ __ ] labor day
you know unless you accidentally ran
over somebody's foot
on september 1st there's no [ __ ]
reason to get anybody some flowers
well what if they have a date oh go [ __ ]
yourselves
you know then i got to fill out all this
[ __ ] to to get
[ __ ] 17 it's not even worth it to me
all right so pro flowers if you're
listening
i will see you in february
um anyways this is like reverse
good business so anyways what the [ __ ]
am i talking about did anybody watch any
college football how great is it that
football's back
did anybody get suckered into that uh
michigan alabama game like i did
i had the [ __ ] fellas over you know
my woman my piece of property is
um she'd kill me if i ever said that is
[ __ ] uh
she's out of town so what am i gonna do
there's only two options either i get
some hookers and i cheat on her
or i have the fellas come over and i
[ __ ]
get hammered i chose the ladder
look at me i'm still [ __ ] i just
can't drink like i used to man
i picked up a cigar habit you know
oh anyways
so yeah number eight michigan first
[ __ ] number two
alabama and in my head i'm going why is
michigan number eight
how are they number eight they sucked
last year what happened who did they get
this did a couple of [ __ ] beasts from
penn state
you know but even then you're only
allowed to sign one what the [ __ ]
happened
how were these guys number eight and
about i don't know when alabama was up
like 21-0 or something like
right in the beginning of the second
quarter that's when i figured it out oh
they weren't number eight they just made
them number eight so i would tune in
and invite my [ __ ] friends over like
an [ __ ]
we watched like seven minutes of that
game and then that was it we were
downstairs
[ __ ] hanging out at the grill you
know i took out my climbing rope
because everybody oh you climb a rope i
can [ __ ] do that and people are drunk
trying to go up and down the rope
you know back in the day that would be
funny to me and all i'm thinking
in my head the whole time is somebody's
gonna fall and they're gonna break their
hip and then i'm gonna get sued
all right and that's what it means to
become old
you know when you're young when your
friends fall down you can just laugh
when you're old there's
somebody has to pay for it
[Laughter]
there's a liability ah jesus why didn't
i bet that game
i maybe do do i just know it because now
the game's over but if ever there was a
[ __ ]
layup everybody what about deny robbing
[ __ ] dude
he's so [ __ ] he's [ __ ] sec fest
and now he's playing an sec team
okay which means you regular
[ __ ]
he just became another [ __ ]
quarterback and that was it he actually
made a couple of nice throws
but uh i don't know
a bunch of [ __ ] people all in that
goddamn stadium
who honestly who the [ __ ] would buy
flowers in september you know what i
mean
why are we selling flowers that's that
corporate mentality
why don't you just make all your money
on on [ __ ]
valentine's day and then you make the
rest of your money the back end
the back nine you make on mother's day
and you call it a year
and go sit on your [ __ ] boat you know
what if what if we just created this
need for flowers
12 months out of the year what if you
just left them in the ground and you let
them continue to produce
oxygen for us why don't you do that
instead of ripping them out of the
[ __ ] ground every goddamn day no
oh jesus i am on a [ __ ] tear here um
you know what it is no bill what is it
i am uh i'm getting geared up i'm doing
six
straight [ __ ] weeks on the road
six straight my year is basically over
summer's over the summer's over i'm
going on the road
i'm coming to you
with dick jokes and a closing [ __ ]
joke and that's it for you
[Music]
by the time you realize you got [ __ ]
over
i'll have your money in my wallet
i'm [ __ ] doing i'm [ __ ] doing the
white trash tour
what do you mean by the white trash the
white trash tour listen to the cities
that i am going to
this week i'm going to be on orlando
florida
okay and unless you have kids and you
want to go visit a giant [ __ ] mouse
with a struggling actor inside of it
there's no [ __ ] reason to go there if
you're some [ __ ] and you want to go
blow tiger woods i guess that's another
reason to go there
i don't know why else would you go to
orlando to buy some bait
you know so i'm going there first and
then
next week i'm going to be in charlotte
charlotte north carolina eastbound down
loaded up and trucking
we didn't realize the civil war had
ended um i'm going there
going to the comedy zone
and uh then i go to new york city
oh i'm standing next to a bunch of [ __ ]
that must mean i'm successful too right
let's get it sliced i'm going there
and then the week after that i go to
jacksonville florida
this is how bad jacksonville is
people in jacksonville go to orlando to
vacation
all right
[Laughter]
jacksonville jacksonville is another one
of those cities that if it started to
if there was a flood you know you think
you had it bad in new orleans if
if jacksonville literally fell into the
sea
i think it would take at least i would
say
36 hours before like
that like that news actually hit the
national airwaves
you know 36 hours after an entire
metropolis
fell into the ocean somebody would
finally come on tv be like
uh we have a developing story something
going on in jacksonville florida
certainly southeastern northeastern
thank you thank you robert the
northeastern part of the state like no i
won't even [ __ ] know
what goes on in jacksonville
you had a usfl team back in the day
right
the florida gators and the [ __ ]
georgia bulldogs play there once a year
and everybody comes to town they drink
their beer and they [ __ ] you women
you know and they drive out and then
that's it becomes quiet again a couple
of tumbleweeds blow across
you know you got the jaguars
that's actually pretty amazing you know
for a city to get a professional
franchise
when they have no other professional
franchises like as late in the game as
jacksonville got a [ __ ] team you know
what i mean
like take uh let's say portland
portland oregon they got a basketball
team i could see them maybe getting a
baseball team
you know hey they got a basketball team
they're showing up for that let's
[ __ ] try this right
jacksonville had nothing nada
zero zilch they had nothing
the florida gators and georgia bulldogs
play there
because it's some neutral [ __ ] in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere it's like a
musical
you know what i mean like when they have
like uh the two gangs are gonna fight
before they do they're gonna walk in a
circle snapping their fingers right
this stupid [ __ ] jeans rolled up for
some
unknown reason other than probably the
sexuality of most of the guys in the
play
is this how tough guys do it
um anyways so that's what i'm doing
and then after that i go to cincinnati
ohio in cincinnati ohio that's one of
those zombie cities
there's all these great hard-working
people
right up until 4 59 in the afternoon and
right at five it's like the fred
flintstone they all slide down the
brontosaurus get in their goddamn cars
and they vacate the city
and then all that is left is drug
addicts unbelievably poor people
and the comedian working at the club
walking that's what's walking down the
street at 501
as the sun starts to go down you know
what i mean
you start you know it's probably the
same feeling like you know
that zebra has and that that split
second where in is
is peripheral when ever the whole herd's
scattered
and you don't know why and you start to
feel the breath of an alligator and
you're like ah [ __ ]
i guess it's me today right
jesus bill is cincinnati that bad you
know what go visit it
go visit it
did i even mention any dates
jesus what the [ __ ] what kind of way is
that to sell a goddamn tour
that was like reverse rock singer right
there where
[ __ ] rock singers would go out there
and be like let me tell you something
jacksonville
we've done a lot of cities on this tour
but i gotta tell you and i think the
fellas behind me will agree
when it comes to crowds right just
[ __ ]
jerking them off
the reason why i'm excited to go to
these cities i just want to see what the
[ __ ] people do in these cities
i've already been to orlando i know what
that that's just a bunch of [ __ ]
strip malls
those adobe structures
you know the excitement out there you
want to go to five guys burgers and
fries you want to go down there
you been there who do they make the best
goddamn burgers
you know they probably all look down on
disney world
you know bunch of [ __ ] posers like
that's how you like you're a rebel in
orlando as you trash disney world
you know i don't know why why would you
continue this way
you know what it is it's not going to be
the shows
it's not going to be the people that
come up to me after the shows and say
something mildly racist
you know it's not going to be that it's
it's going to be the getting on and
getting off of [ __ ] airplanes
oh jesus this is like the tampon [ __ ]
menstrual cramp [ __ ] podcast right
now shouldn't i feel lucky that i have
this amount of work
you know when all those glass workers
got laid off recently out there in
dayton ohio
then they just closed down the glass
factory do you know they're not gonna
make glasses in this country anymore
anywhere
they're all gonna be made in the
philippines i saw the whole thing on
60 minutes do you guys watch the last
episode of breaking bad did anybody see
it
there's a bunch of [ __ ] psychos right
now covering their ears
i i i can't recommend that show enough
it's not because old twinkle toes got in
a couple of episodes here it's just
it's the most unbelievable [ __ ] show
i've ever seen
they just keep they just keep
twisting it tighter and tighter and
tighter
and every time you think you can breathe
you know because some problem got
[ __ ] solved something else comes
along and it's even [ __ ] worse
unreal i'm not going to say anything
that ha i probably shouldn't even
brought it up because there's probably
half the [ __ ] people who listen to
this aren't even listening right now for
fear
that you know i was gonna give away
something from the show
i'm not gonna do that all right this is
the monday morning podcast everybody if
you're new to this show
um welcome welcome aboard if you live in
any of the cities i just trashed uh i
stand by that
that wasn't a joke now i know what i i
know what i'm gonna do in charlotte
charlotte i'm gonna go visit uh
streetside customs
i'm gonna go check out the old cars
there that's what i'm gonna do there
new york city come on it's new york i'll
be fine orlando i have no idea what the
[ __ ] i'm gonna do
i tried to find some college football i
something
i don't know what i'm gonna do i think
i'm gonna walk from the air-conditioned
comedy condo to the club and then go
back but i'm actually excited to be
there because i've never done that one
let's let's try to put a little positive
shine on this [ __ ] white trash tour
here
and uh jacksonville
um there's got to be some redneck [ __ ]
going on there's got to be some sort of
rattlesnake roundup
you know some sort of gun show
you know two rednecks with their trucks
chained together trying to drive in
different directions
whoever ends up with the other guys
differential wins you know
can i go to something like that is there
[ __ ] something for me to do there
but actually uh when i'm in charlotte
i'm gonna go to the panthers game
carolina panthers game and when i'm in
jacksonville
i'm going to go to a [ __ ] jaguars
game and when i go to cincinnati i'm
going to a bengals game see that that's
how i do the [ __ ] road
that's how that's how i do it pointing
at himself with a thumb um
all right here we go
let's let's get let's get this let's get
some stuff out of the way here e-voice
everybody this
is like this is taking off like wildfire
you know that cleo
i know you're just laying there with not
a [ __ ] excited bone in your body but
i'm telling you e-voice
e-voice is uh is is is killing it
and you're probably saying hey bill what
is uh what is e-voice
e-voice is basically your mobile phone
at work
okay you can get all kinds of different
phone numbers
uh oh i always forget the word virtual
virtual phone numbers like wouldn't it
be great if you could give some guy some
guy coming up to you and he wants to buy
your widgets
right and you want to give them your
phone number but you don't want to give
them your real phone number
right but you don't want to have 20 cell
phones
all right with e-voice you can have a
whole bunch of different phone numbers
all ring on your cell phone
but nobody really knows your number all
they know is those other ones
right did that make sense did i just get
lost in the math of that
um it basically it creates a way that
you can uh actually make it seem like
you have an office building in the
beginning when you really don't
they got music on hold they have
professional voice over
people to be like hola donde es
lay something or other right whatever
english accent whatever you want
they're going to make you sound
professional like this is probably the
best way that i can think
if you're starting off a business or if
you already have them but if you're
starting a business
taking that crucial step to get yourself
out of that cubicle
and make your dreams come true today
is to get like you got to have some sort
of infrastructure going
okay but that costs money you know what
i mean usually it costs you a bunch of
money but with e-voice it's not going to
cost you a bunch of money
you just sign up for the stuff and
you're good to go uh one of the great
e-voice
uh features is music on hold makes your
business seem more professional as
e-voice will treat your clients and
customers to music on hold
you can even set up e-voice to run a
promotional advertisement for your
company
while you're on hold instead of the
music e-voice also has the call
recording feature
which is perfect for doctors lawyers
real estate agents hiring managers or
any other professionals
uh discussing contracts you can do
conference calls with up to 95 people
you know in case you're in some sort of
worldwide drug cartel meeting i don't
know what you need 95 people for but
just in case you do
evoice is there for when you have your
95 person
can you dig it uh conference call
um it's easy to use you just press two
to start and two to stop
perfect if you're driving and can't
write something important down
e-voice makes your life easier and seem
more professional for a free six-month
trial go to
com www.evoice.com bill burr uh once
again www.evoice.com
billboard or go to the banner ad on my
podcast page at billbird.com
um i really hope you guys start
utilizing this and uh
no bs i've been getting some great
feedback from people out there from
listeners who are trying to start their
own business
this is the perfect thing you know
and if you're starting a business do you
want to pay taxes like a regular lunch
pail larry
i don't think you do wouldn't it be
great if you could get incorporated for
a very low amount of money
well let me tell you this at legal zoom
um you've probably heard about legalzoom
but i'm telling you about them right now
you got to check them out
these guys are phenomenal um if you've
been waiting for the perfect time to
start your dream business it's right now
incorporate your business or form an llc
at legalzoom.com starting at just 99
bucks i paid 1500 to do this when i went
through a lawyer
um and if you have a family guess what
you need to make sure that they're
protected too you can protect your
family and assets with the legal zoom
will
for just 69 in the past 12 years over 2
million americans have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks and
more
this is the way this is the way to go
all right and if you get too confused
they even have attorneys that will help
you out
uh if you need it through their legal
plans um start your business and protect
your family at legalzoom.com
you could also get a special discount
from listening to this podcast make sure
you enter
in the referral box that's b-u-r-r
at the checkout for more savings
legalzoom is not a law firm and
self-help services are provided at your
direction
in other words if you need help ask for
it all right
so back to the podcast here
hey you know what i want to buy a
pegboard hanging that up in my garage
i'm basically starting my own little gym
here it's all body weight i got a
climbing rope
i got a dip station pull-up thing and
then i get that pegboard
right and i'll be able to go up and down
it with my skinny little legs hanging
off because i'm not doing any squats
you know what i want to do is a buddy of
mine was telling me uh on joe rogan's
podcast he's got this whole
uh those kettlebell workout
i heard his listeners are going nuts
getting all jacked doing that i want to
do it
so if anybody knows what podcast
of rogan's i gotta listen to um where he
basically breaks it down
and then i'll do my cheap ass version of
it when i'm on the road
by basically going out and buying two
grapefruits and putting them in plastic
bags
what dude let's just say principles um
advice all right bill
boner problems oh jesus christ there we
go dear bill i'm approaching my 27th
birthday
and in the past couple of weeks i've had
some issues with getting erect
uh uh all right oh oh jesus okay here we
go
instead of getting wood having sex or
looking at porn i now have to fiddle
with myself
just to get hard i don't know if this is
due to mild
dude this is so [ __ ] beyond
this is a dr drew question all right so
don't listen to me but i gotta make this
funny dude all right so fast forward
this because i don't want to add to your
psychological problems
um i don't know if this is due to mild
uh depression caused by stress being
overweight or
i'm just getting old and this is how i'm
going to be i am overweight but since
april i've been steadily losing weight
and exercising good for you
i do have mild depression i know where
you're coming from i got it too
and i've had bouts of erectile
dysfunction in the past
but they usually don't last more than a
few days
um yeah i don't know what to tell you
i would say don't rub one out for a
couple of days
you know and then stand on your back
porch with your junk hanging out and
imagine the first time the wind blows i
think you'll be in the game
that's my advice and it's off to chicago
and let's win there
yeah i don't know what to tell you dude
like i i would i would seek some sort of
professional help see if you got a
circulation problem
um but i think the biggest thing you're
doing which is great is you're losing
weight
because uh you know you eat too many
[ __ ] cinnabons it clogs up the
plumbing
and i know that because i don't have a
medical degree
um ignoring girlfriend's past
bill i am an aussie with a beautiful
girlfriend
oh speaking of australians i'm going to
sydney
in uh in october you see what i just did
there this guy's
you know actually he basically started a
conversation with with me and i just
interrupted him
i'm being that douche at the party right
now but i actually you guys have seen
did you see that video where the [ __ ]
little aussie bullies punching the
fat-headed [ __ ] kid
who i like outweighs them by 80 pounds
and finally the the kid getting bullied
just can't take it anymore and he just
picks this kid up and i can't even
like lifts him up basically a little
above his head
and if he just dropped him there that
would have been amazing but he like
[ __ ] it was like he was wringing out
a mat
is how he threw this kid down to the
[ __ ] ground
like shaking out a beach towel except it
was his kid's ragdoll body
like his the kid's whole body did the
[ __ ] worm except when he came back
he's
from like six feet in the air and he
slammed this kid on the ground
i couldn't believe this kid's legs still
worked it was [ __ ]
awesome but now they got
like they have like it's become this
entire like mini series
they interviewed the kid who got bullied
and then they interviewed the kid
who did the bullying and funny the
bully's crying
and he's trying to say that the fatty
[ __ ] was hitting him first
which is total [ __ ] because if you
look at the fat kid which i really
should be saying but
you know you know i'm just trying to you
know i only have so many minutes here in
the podcast the husky kid
the [ __ ] kid punches him in the face
and he just stands there with his hands
down to his side
he could tell you know if he was walking
around hitting people his whole body
language would have
a different i didn't believe the little
mosquito looking kid
but um and then so they interview both
of them and then they have the two of
them
interviewing each other and i gotta tell
you
i don't think i've ever laughed so
[ __ ] hard
in my entire life not because i think
it's right or i think it's funny i just
[ __ ] there's just something about it
it just took me back to my childhood
just how [ __ ] mean kids are
they'd be like well what was like what
was it like when when when when you went
to school
like what were some of what were some of
the things the kids used to call you i
know this is a brutal [ __ ] aussie
accent
um but he'd be like oh you know they
call me uh
they call me fatty
and with every mean name i'm
laughing my ass off it literally gets to
the point where the kid said he was
suicidal
and i've been through all of that i've
been through all of it
and i actually sat there laughing my ass
off watching it and i'm asking you guys
why am i laughing i don't find it funny
i feel bad for the kid but with the
meaner the detail is
the harder i [ __ ] laugh
i don't know if that i don't know if
that's like some sort of like uh
fallout from trauma where after a while
you just like it just becomes
funny there's like nothing what else are
you gonna do
like i remember every [ __ ] movie i go
to see i know i've told these stories a
zillion times but this
if this actually fits it like i remember
when i saw
sling blade and when that
country singer dwight yoakam when he
zoomed the guy in the wheelchair out of
the house watch go home and practice
randy and he get the [ __ ] out of my
house
and he [ __ ] zoomed that guy in the
wheelchair and the guy in the wheelchair
like
it did like the whiplash thing went
through the front door
like the people
who were watching the movie around were
either quiet or
gasping and i was roaring laughing
and not that i think that's like it's do
you know what i mean like it's it's so
wrong it's it's funny
i'm probably coming off like a maniac i
did that one time we were flying over
the [ __ ]
one of those magical kingdoms over there
in europe where they got a starbucks
next to a [ __ ] castle you know
and uh i was sitting in the aisle nia's
in the middle seat and then there was
some girl on the window
and uh yes i was flying coach
um to go do the funny bone in [ __ ]
afghanistan and uh
i was watching a movie on a laptop
and i was laughing so hard at one point
i was [ __ ] wheezing
and it was one of those deals where i'm
laughing so hard people around me are
laughing
just at how hard i'm at like the girl on
the window was laughing at how hard i
was laughing
and i was laughing so hard that i woke
nia up and knee woke up and immediately
was like laughing like what the [ __ ] are
you
laughing at and then she leaned over you
know because you can't see in the
computer screen she leaned over
and saw that i was watching uh precious
and um you know she starts punching me
in the arm which made it even funnier
and then the girl
by the window found it even funnier
i totally got lost in that [ __ ] story
i don't know what point i'm trying to
make like i'm trying to ask you why do i
find [ __ ] like that hilarious
you know like whenever i watch the
biggest loser
and they'll be like you know so how do
you feel about yourself you you're
[ __ ]
zeppelin you you know and the guy will
be like oh you know i have my good days
and i have my bad days and
uh then his voice cracks and his [ __ ]
forehead wrinkles up and he just starts
[ __ ] crying like a baby
i i i i [ __ ] laugh
i laugh like i'm watching stripes
intervention you know
intervention when the family starts
reading
their letters of pain to the [ __ ]
degenerate drug addict
and uh they start [ __ ] crying i
i immediately i just start roaring
laughing
like it's the funny like i get more
laughs out of that than if i was
watching one of those sitcoms with the
good looking people in the couch
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about um
anyways let's get on with the podcast
here
oh australia the australia guy right
uh if anybody knows what that is if
there's actually anybody with any
well look i was just gonna say if
there's some sort of psychologist
listening to this [ __ ]
as if i deserve professional
opinion after you guys listen to my
[ __ ] [ __ ] opinion every week
whatever if you're a plumber i'd like to
hear what you think all right ignoring
girlfriend's
past bill i'm an aussie with a beautiful
girlfriend
how the hell do i stop picturing her
getting nailed by guys she's dated
before me
i'm torching myself with these thoughts
we have great sex and everything
yeah how do you think she got that way
to use the dice clay line
from bang and all those other people sir
from what i understand
it's something no one likes to think
about
dude i'm just breaking your balls all
right
look if you love this girl
you just you gotta get past the fact
that she sucked other dicks you know
probably enjoyed it no i'm just [ __ ]
with you now um
that was me how do you get past it
um
i never think about it i just look i
look at women like uh
you just picked up a [ __ ] free agent
that's got you know good [ __ ] career
stats here
that shows that they can get the job
done you know they can perform in
october
you know what i mean
just look at it like that way it's like
the dodgers just picking up all those
red sox they got gonzales you know
anything that they cared that he [ __ ]
was playing baseball
in some other town they don't give a
[ __ ] just come in here and get the
goddamn job done
so we can win the championship that's
how you got to look at it
all right if she shows up and she's
clean she doesn't have any go what about
you sir next time she's [ __ ] blowing
you
thinking about think about all the
[ __ ] trolls at the truck stop that
you left put put their mouths on you
and now she's down there you know
there's not enough shampoo and
conditioner to clean your dick
past a certain [ __ ] age and that's
the goddamn truth and you don't say
anything about that right
as you put it inside of her give me a
[ __ ] break
all right sir it is what it is
she's banged other people you're gonna
have to get past it and uh
i can guarantee you this she probably
hasn't been with remotely the amount of
people that you have
not to mention some of the [ __ ]
complete tramps
that uh you know what i mean
i like to think that women a little more
uh have a little more discretion
and my issues with women right now it
just kills me that i'm saying something
pro-female because i know they're all
[ __ ] nodding
that's right that's right um
yeah this is one way or the other
they're either really discretionary or
they're just [ __ ]
whomping [ __ ] that was a
generalization i apologize um
friends unholy wedding
dude i was doing so great on this
[ __ ] podcast i don't know it's
somewhere i lost
the [ __ ] momentum i lost my mojo when
i was talking about why i laugh
you know at people with the [ __ ]
crutches
falling down a flight of stairs i don't
know why i got into that uh friends
unholy wedding bill i got a problem that
i don't think i can go
go to my friends with a friend of mine
is getting married
i've been good friends with the guy
since we were five years old
and we are now 23. he's getting married
about a year from now he has selected me
to be the groomsman
all right i'm guessing either you [ __ ]
his wife
future wife or she's banged
you know 70 people or is [ __ ] around
on him that's what i'm guessing
um or she's into the devil one of the
other this has to be wise this is an
unholy wedding
all right he's getting married about a
year from now good you got time
he he is uh selected
sorry nia just was calling in she's
going to kill me
he's calling from another [ __ ]
country and i just shut it off because i
had to
i got to finish this [ __ ] podcast
you're putting the podcast ahead of me
yes um he's getting married about a year
from now he has selected me to be a
groomsman
this means i have to to pay for a flight
to attend the wedding
furthermore his bachelor party is being
you cheap [ __ ] this is what it's
going to be about money
all right this me i [ __ ] hate oh
hang on a second the lovely nia
everybody
nia
hey listen i'm doing the podcast can i
call you right back
say hello to the podcast listeners
tally ho i'll talk to you later
see that she had a [ __ ] hard day and
i'm not there for what a piece of [ __ ]
all right let's get back to tightwat
here and i have to buy a tuxedo you know
uh a rent one uh this means i have to
pay for a flight to attend the wedding
furthermore his bachelor party is being
held in las vegas and i would also have
to pay for this flight as well as other
expenses of a bachelor party
normally this wouldn't be an issue i'm a
college student and saving
the approximately a thousand dollars
this would cost would be
uh would be stressful but it would be
worth it to see one of my greatest
friends get married
okay so you're not a cheap [ __ ] you're
just having money problems however my
friend has often lied to
and cheated on his fiancee oh
i didn't see that one coming why didn't
i guess that there you go
there's a whole new [ __ ]
jesus uh i'm not judging him
i just i disapprove of how he treats her
this guy's actually a good [ __ ] and i
actually called him a piece of whatever
i judge you on your first couple of
sentences what are you gonna do he goes
i disapprove of how he treats her but i
don't get myself
involved he sleeps around and hides from
her the fact
that he smokes pot and drinks heavily on
a daily basis
i don't know how she hasn't noticed
she's probably because she's a
sweetheart
sweethearts always end up with [ __ ]
dicks like this
she's never smoked or cheated uh as far
as you know
i don't understand why he doesn't find a
different relationship but again
i don't get myself involved the problem
is i can't imagine this marriage will
last very long and i don't want to pay a
thousand dollars for a shared marriage
at a time when a thousand dollars is
like the lottery to me
i'm actually offended that he's asked me
to do all of this
for the wedding and thus spend all this
money
i cannot imagine asking any of my
friends to throw away that much money on
something i didn't give a [ __ ] about
should i decline to attend the wedding
any advice would be appreciated
i don't know if i can go to our other
friends with this one
um
all right there's as always there's a
million different ways you can play this
there's two options three options
all right one you just [ __ ]
bite your tongue and you just go to the
goddamn wedding
and think that all right even though
it's gonna [ __ ] blow up maybe he'll
learn something from it and then uh
you know by the time he's 30 he'll grow
up and you guys can actually be friends
again
two you [ __ ]
did i say there was three i already
forgot the other one so there's only
going to be two here
[Laughter]
oh why do you guys listen to this you
know you know why because it makes you
feel better doesn't it it should
good i i feel like i'm serving a purpose
now um
just sit the guy down and be like dude
can i ask you a question
yeah sure man yeah what's up what the
[ __ ] are you doing
what am i doing i mean what the why are
you getting married
because i love her where is this going
dude
you're [ __ ] everything that moves i
walk slower when i'm around you
that's how much [ __ ] that you're [ __ ]
do you understand me do you understand
where i'm coming from
and you're asking me to go out she
doesn't know your booze she doesn't know
that you smoke weed
you know i this is a thousand bucks
if you actually you know
this is like me flying
to go see the [ __ ] i don't know go
see at the padres versus the [ __ ]
colorado rockies what is the [ __ ]
point you know
yeah you're a piece of [ __ ] this
marriage isn't gonna last
and what's worse is you're doing it in
front of me and then i i gotta sit there
and have a conversation
you know i got to figure out what part
of her face i'm going to look at because
i can't look at her in the eye
you're dragging me into it ah jesus this
is bad advice
i mean you gotta at least don't say it
that way just be like listen i don't
have a thousand dollars
i just don't have it to go to the
marriage and then to go to the wedding
start with that and then if he gives you
[ __ ]
just say oh that's your other option
just say listen i just don't have the
money
and you bite your tongue and you look
the other way so you don't see them
the train wreck that's gonna happen
that's the option or you can just come
clean
and just say listen dude i love you to
death you're my buddy
but what you're doing here this is wrong
all right you're not being fair to her
you're not being fair to me and yeah
you're [ __ ]
you're screwing yourself in the long run
so
this is what you want to do go do it but
i don't want to be a part of it
all right
yeah so my guess
is uh your best [ __ ] option as far as
like the least amount of drama
is to uh and mental trauma for yourself
is to do
the one i threw there in the middle we
just said listen i just don't have the
money
dude i can't believe i'm supposed to be
your bro
bro it's my wedding dude
i can't believe dude i can't believe
you're [ __ ] everything that moves and
you [ __ ] smoke weed in your booze
every day
and this girl doesn't even know how
about that and you're acting like you're
not doing it even into [ __ ] me and
you expect me to stand there do you
understand that you understand that i
realized
that you're [ __ ] everything that
moves right now and you're gonna go
marry this girl
and i'm about to sit there and watch you
toast this girl i love you you're
the uh the the blood that pumps through
my heart that [ __ ] i gotta sit there
staring at my [ __ ] lasagna
you know there's gonna be lasagna
anytime you gotta cook for more than
[ __ ] 10 people they just make a big
tray of that [ __ ] we have a meat base we
have a vegetarian isn't that big [ __ ]
silver tray
all right here's the last one oh this is
a short podcast 50 minutes
satan this person says bill
if satan punishes the bad doesn't that
make him good
and that's from a lady
um yeah i don't get the math on that
like most things when it comes to
religion it doesn't it doesn't add up
it's like
satan was in heaven right how the [ __ ]
does it go isn't it
an iron maiden song can i just go listen
to like die with your boots on and i'll
know how this story goes like i don't
or judas priests you know
point of entry or screaming for
vengeance don't they have a song about
it
whatever satan was basically you know
he was like the zildjian brothers before
they had a fight and then one broke off
and created sabian
right how about something a little more
mainstream
it was like bill gates and steve jobs
right when they were having a little
circle jerk around a [ __ ]
trs 80 or whatever the [ __ ] they were
doing in their little fort
you know playing dungeons and dragons
playing poker for each other's loafers
whatever the [ __ ] they did then they
went their separate ways
whatever satan was in the club
but he wanted to run [ __ ]
what did he do the [ __ ] did the guy do
again
somehow he pissed off god
oh i know he tried to take over he tried
to take god's position
and god was like oh no you didn't right
and then cast him into this [ __ ]
pit of fire that never goes out
but somehow satan is such a bad
[ __ ]
that he sits in the flames and adapted
you know what i mean like somebody back
in the day that had bronchitis so they'd
send him out to the desert to [ __ ]
dry out like that was gonna cure you he
actually got cured to the point now
satan's down there and it's just
chilling oh look who got
up oh cleo get over here
now you gotta itch [ __ ] it for nine
hours um
yeah so now he's down there like [ __ ]
uh
you know lucky luciano hanging out at
the [ __ ] flamingo
and then you go down there
you go down you basically live your life
the way he wanted you to
and then you show up at the club and
then he's mad at you and then kicks the
[ __ ] out of you
it doesn't make any sense and
technically he's then punishing you
for doing what he did
is it like uh like that's like the mail
room like god's mail room
so he's sitting there sorting envelopes
like he's still working for god i don't
i really don't know how it works i
actually went to church this week oh
gg shogi
i went there and the second i walk in i
just can't like i
i don't buy into any of it i went with
uh
i went with nia's mom we went to church
and uh what i try to do when i go in
there is go above all of it
and try to like you know connect with
something like whoopi goldberg and ghost
you know try to connect with something
else other than what they said like
literally what they're preaching it's
like
i i know
you guys had the holy wars you had the
[ __ ] inquisition i mean
you [ __ ] you know when jewish people
after world war ii were trying to get
their [ __ ] back
like the amount of stuff that went into
the vatican i mean
you were down with the nazis like how is
this plate like
how did penn state lose all those
victories
right lost all those victories and what
happened to the catholic church you know
i've i've talked about this a zillion
[ __ ] times
they have broken on a global
level every major [ __ ] commandment
that there is
and they just sit there holy holy
[Music]
holy
[ __ ] tell me how to live my life
um yeah i just don't buy into it
and then the money basket came around
i'm giving these [ __ ] [ __ ]
as with nia's mom and i was like i don't
want to be an [ __ ] in front of us so
i threw five bucks in there
five bucks i just paid five dollars for
the [ __ ] defense attorney in a
pedophile case
kind of telling me i'm not going to hell
right then for being so goddamn stupid
yeah it was uh then they had the guy
they had the this irish tenor guy who
was singing all the songs keep in mind
and he would do like this big conducting
thing he was like totally [ __ ] into
it to get the crowd going right he had
this
awful suit on that didn't fit him you
know
looks like he ate donuts and [ __ ] and
they didn't the guy in the
the preacher gave him a [ __ ] shout
out he goes this week
ah we would like to extend it
congratulations to uh
that guy over there and can't fit into
his sport coat
for 20 years of singing songs here
this church and i want to say here's to
another
50 years here at this church nobody
clapped and it's like he's going to be
dead in 50. we're all going to be
i'll be dead well maybe not right 94.
hey what's the deal with dentures um
that's gonna be a sad [ __ ] day me
[ __ ] wheeling my ass under the stage
[ __ ] at 94 years old
you know somebody with a jetsons haircut
interviewing me before the show
do you still enjoy it do you still enjoy
every night that i could get out there
and bring a smile
to people's faces um
[ __ ] sitting there instead of like
bottled water backstage
i'll have like vital organs being grown
to be inserted in me before i go out
there
that's like the level of uh uh that
won't be available to me
dick cheney will have that [ __ ] he'll
still be walking around
um anyways what the [ __ ] was i just
talking about
oh yeah it's not a fifth day here
they're at he's gonna be
dead look at him
he's like 40 pounds over [ __ ] weight
he's sliding into 50 at about 90 miles
an hour without a helmet on the way this
guy's [ __ ] eating he's not he's not
going to make it
he probably has some [ __ ] horrific
collection of porn he's not wearing a
wedding ring this
[ __ ] he's sweaty like
what is he doing this guy's sad he has
no [ __ ] life
i feel bad for him let's get him a
haircut get him a gym membership
and how about we make the last seven
years of his [ __ ] life enjoyable how
about that why don't we go out and get a
harlot for this guy
you know the physical equivalent to a
dozen donuts he'll be able to relate
you know i'm not even saying any of
that's true people
that's just what was going through my
head when i was there
there was some guy in the pew i hate
that word pew
um in front of me and he just looked
like an evil [ __ ]
you know he was balding he was like in
his uh
he was like pushing 60. he was tan
he had [ __ ] balding but he still was
dying his hair jet black
and he had a pinky ring and a bracelet
on right there pinky ring and a bracelet
you're a dishonest [ __ ] all
right
unless you're a chick if you're a guy
and you're wearing that
you know that dr vinnie boombot's
[ __ ]
outfit that's it you're a piece of [ __ ]
and he just ah when he looked over me
pieced me with you
i want to be like [ __ ] you
that what do you mean what you know what
it's for whatever the [ __ ] you did since
last sunday
with your pinky ring in your bracelet i
think jesus christ i think i was just
sitting there judging people
you know they had altered girls you know
instead of the altar boys just to keep
the priests honest
you know which i thought was brilliant
that's a brilliant way
to keep them away from little boys is to
let girls do it because they were all
girls there was no boys there
what else can i trash about it
i can't remember you know i i he gave
the homily and i didn't remember one
[ __ ] thing that he said
he wasn't miked well i couldn't
understand what he was saying
that was my that was my little trip to
[ __ ] church but i went
but i went and i actually saw the
confessionals and i was thinking jesus
the [ __ ] that i have to get off my chest
and then but then i always think like
what the [ __ ] do i want to tell this guy
why do i got to go in there tell it to
you and then it goes
then you run it up the [ __ ] line
you know [ __ ] weirdo
you just want to hear all the bad [ __ ]
that i did because you're not allowed to
go out and
[ __ ] bang abroad ah
jesus bill you just you just you're just
going over old [ __ ]
points you've already made we get it oh
you don't like this [ __ ]
all right let's uh let's let's conclude
here
with let's let's try to bring this
around to something positive
all right um
let's start with the video games
video games why don't you like um
video games see that i always come up
with like a jingle for everybody uh
amazon.com no that's the wrong one
gamefly.com
everybody did i don't say baby
gameflat.com baby
um all right would you like to play 8
000 video games
get a two-week free trial huh a 23
value jesus christ
that's what it costs 23 bucks it's it's
almost free anyways and they're giving
it to you for free
let me tell you something if i played
video games i would go to gamefly.com
i'd go to www.gamefly.com
or click on the banner ad on my podcast
page and get a free trial
and i would enjoy eight thousand video
games for two weeks and you know what i
do after two weeks
i'd give them 23 bucks for a membership
and i put on my virtual glasses and i
would go to another world
and i would kill the bad things right
and when i couldn't do it i would get
frustrated then i would go online and
i'd find the cheats and i'd get all the
weapons and i would finish the game in
20 minutes
it would make me feel good right
then i would yell out at other people
because i would feel guilty
um anyways yeah gamefly.com slash burr
go on there get all the video games you
that you could possibly ever want stack
them all up around your face
and you won't have to deal with the
world anymore all right amazon.com would
you like to help out this podcast
and support the troops um
go to billboard.com click on the banner
ad
anytime you're going to buy something on
amazon just do that click on the banner
ad
the amazon banner ad on my podcast page
it'll bring you directly to amazon.com
you don't have to do anything else go
out there go buy yourself a ladle
whatever the hell you're looking for a
pegboard possibly
like what i'm going to buy later on
after this podcast
and um they kick me a percentage of
whatever you know people buy
and then i take a percentage of that i
basically i'm kicking an overall 10
as i say every week of the advertising
money that i make
i send it over to the wounded warriors
project it's a great damn thing
and uh why not after this last hour of
filth and all the horrible things that
i've said
it's nice that i can bring it around to
this this uh nice little moment here
you know holy
holy all right that's the [ __ ]
podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves um that's it that's the
podcast for this week
please come out and see me at the first
stop on the white trash tour
um in at the uh where the hell am i
going to be i'm at the improv
in orlando florida would you like the
exact dates
you want me to hold your hand through
this whole thing
i know where orlando is but when am i
supposed to be there
oh this [ __ ] computer come on orlando
improv
september 7th 8th and 9th
it says september 7th and 8th is that
true i thought i was there for three
days
thursday friday saturdays when i'm there
comedy zone
charlotte september 13th 14th and 15th
and i'll see you at the game on sunday
um oh by the way if anybody has any
ideas of some [ __ ] that i can go to
a gun store something that's gonna
[ __ ] be a cool thing to do
in any of these cities for the love of
god let me know because god knows the
travel channel never comes to your towns
caroline's the makeup date from july i'm
going to be there september 20 21
22 and 23 and i will be there
with the teen idol sensation from the
opium anthony program
the one and only joe joey rose's derosa
okay this is his farewell performance as
a feature act
okay this is literally the end of an era
um i can't even say he's arguably the
greatest feature
act of all time he is the greatest
feature act of all time
and uh we want to thank him all the
headliners
in this country for his dedicated
service in the uh feature position for
all of these years
um he stayed there longer than he had it
than he had to
kind of like a blue chip prospect in
college sports who leaves after his
freshman or sophomore year
joe is like the tim duncan of feature
acts he did all four years
and this is his farewell performance um
of course he's going to get even more
dressed up than usual
uh which usually is the one thing that
if i could criticize him is the way he
always outdresses me as a feature
but um he always pulls back the reins on
his talent
you know because he chooses what's good
for the show
over what's good for joey rose's okay
and that's why he's the he's the
greatest of all time
he did things in the feature position
that have never been done before
and uh and in the opening in the opening
slot is sean patton one of my favorite
new comics out there
it's going to be a great show all of us
have drinking problems so we'll be at
the bar
afterwards please come by and say hello
but don't overstay you're welcome if you
know what i'm saying right come by
little [ __ ] high five
get a picture with joey roses on his
final performance and then move
keep it moving all right unless there's
somebody there that's gonna show us
their tits
okay i think that that's reasonable i
think that's a nice little zone that we
can exist in can't we
um
then the comedy zone in jacksonville
florida okay i have never been here
before if this is literally carved into
the side of a [ __ ]
barn right next to a check cashing store
it will not surprise me i'm really
looking forward
to seeing what human beings look like
like what if you were gonna say like
jacksonville florida
you know you got a cities you got b
cities
sea city like where would you put them
you know what i mean that was like the
other day i was talking to uh
i was talking to somebody and we were
talking about this guy who was dumb but
wasn't mentally challenged and i
basically said
he got the f brain is basically it that
was my way of saying that you know
there's nothing wrong with them he just
got you know there's the a brain the b
brain the c like the a brain would be
[ __ ] you know
bill gates and those types of guys
einstein you get you get the deal right
it's just like grading the paper you get
the f brain you know you failed
you failed at life there's nothing
technically
wrong with your brain uh you know what
it's like a car
you know like when they had the z28 but
they also had like the rally sport with
like a v6 engine and no air conditioning
you got the brain version of that
all right so i'm going into a
city i wouldn't even
when i say jacksonville is an fc i
wouldn't say an f i was it's a d
it's a [ __ ] d all right and you
people in jacksonville if you're [ __ ]
offended by this come out to the show
and i will give you the floor i will
give you a a minute during my show
to stand up like it's a town meeting and
i want you to defend your [ __ ] city
and tell me why it deserves a better
grade than a d
all right you can tell me why you're
better than tampa
you know at the end of the day to use
that overly used expression
um i'm going to be in all of these
cities
so i'm not above them you see that
that's me pretending like i'm being
humble and down to earth right now
hey can i can i talk to you guys about
that right now not being humble or
pretending to be humble
kind of uh the [ __ ] the amount of
hacky [ __ ] that's on the internet
like on twitter that somebody comes up
with something and everybody dives on it
you know like when people do that that
that feeling when
those tweets you know what i mean like
why why would you think when you're like
the 90th [ __ ] person
to do it in the last minute that that's
still [ __ ] cool the shaking my head
you know just a bunch of [ __ ] hacks
and then they'll turn around and
criticize movies and [ __ ]
you know or a guy like kid rock what's
wrong with people
all right oh full of [ __ ] uh
hypocritical bill
that's it i'm done go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great week i know the podcast was
a little late late today but uh you know
it's a day off
stop acting like you were in your
cubicle you weren't doing [ __ ] to get
today right
football season starts who do you like
jesus i can't end this podcast i got to
tell you this i have [ __ ] issue
with the quarterback of my team
all right i saw something very
disturbing
that started you know to start this
season and it had nothing to do with the
horrific past protection that i've seen
in the preseason
it has to do with a particular
quarterback
on the cover of this magazine with a
doberman pinscher
and the doberman's growling and he's
also going like
like the dog too and uh it's just
it's just not a good look i remember
there was a time when this particular
individual said
you know i'm not into commercials and
that i just want to win championships
and now i'm looking at this guy
with his perfect teen idol stubble
on the cover of the magazine as if he
said
hey i have a shoot on tuesday what day
should i stop shaving
um i don't know i'm hoping if i do this
this will be like the reverse jinx well
this will actually make him win a super
bowl this year
okay because we won that thing last year
and [ __ ] choked it away and it still
bugs me
we had that [ __ ] game one we had at
one and we [ __ ] choked it away
do actually i can't say choked it away
because that takes away from the giants
victory i'll say this is what it is
we had the opportunity to win the game
and choked
they then had the opportunity to win the
game and did not they delivered we did
not
all right so i don't know what the [ __ ]
we're on magazine covers for
growling with dogs for when we came in
second doesn't make sense to me
i i don't you know it's like back in the
day when i used to watch peyton manning
you know
lose another [ __ ] playoff game and
next thing you know he's driving down
the [ __ ] street and a pacer waving at
a camera
you know with a gillette razor in his
hand i don't [ __ ] understand that
really bill with 20 minutes of [ __ ]
advertising on your podcast you don't
get it you're dumb [ __ ]
all right i'm out of here see you